and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists hello everybody well welcome
to episode 166 today we're gonna talk
about hope and because we're talking
about hope I thought we'd have a special
guest in here today we know her as Vee
her name's Diane Capaldi right yep
that's perfect but but I just call her
Vee every time we've had coffee before
we've interacted online and now you're
here today because you have a very
hopeful story from a place of deep deep
valley in your life actually you've had
you've traversed several valleys to get
to where you are today and we don't
really do interviews on this podcast
you're gonna help us answer some
questions today but I'd like to give
some context so maybe you could talk a
little bit about your your back story
what's the the big-picture view of who V
is and how we got where we are right now
well I guess I should start with V is
short for verb because I think I'm a
verb and not a noun so that'll give you
a good backstory I'm 55 years old and
proud of it ladies I'm so proud and at
the age of 23 I was diagnosed with
multiple sclerosis and told that I was
going to be bedridden and live a very
non productive life and that it was a
progressive debilitating disease and
just hang on for the ride and my life
was gonna end
you were given a death sentence basic
truly it was a death sentence when t I
was married to my high school sweetheart
six weeks oh yeah what was happening
then you you you said you had some
symptoms I assume or did you just go in
and they randomly assign this this the
this two letter label on right it almost
felt like that no I don't want people to
get their panties in a bunch but I did
get the hepatitis vaccine in the next
day I woke up with symptoms of MS which
ultimately were diagnosed as MS not an
anti-vaxxer I'm just stating my story
yeah oh and also I mean so hepatitis
vaccine I assume covers and I'm a doctor
by any stretch we've had doctors on the
podcast plenty of times and not kook
doctors either but I remember we were we
were living in Missoula the the good
food store there which is the Whole
Foods equivalent yeah there was an
employee who had hepatitis A yeah
there was an employee there who I guess
had who worked the salad bar and had
Pepe and it was like the first thing you
saw in the newspaper was they were
recommending well everyone should if you
ate it the good food store go out and
get a hepatitis A vaccine and I'm like I
guess I should probably do that I've
eaten it this this salad bar two or
three times a week I I should definitely
do that and then I just did a little bit
of like just surface off a research and
I'm like oh like like that there are
some serious potential problems and by
the way if if Hep A if you get happy
it's let's cut it's not the same thing
but it's kind of like getting chickenpox
where once you recover from it you are
effectively vaccinated for the rest of
your life now doctors don't yell at me
please consult your doctor if you want a
real medical advice here we're having a
conversation yeah we're not we're not
recommending anything but so that's
crazy so you got you got this
vaccination you woke up the next day you
started having these symptoms they
diagnosed you with MS so how did that um
if I may like how did that affect your
marriage like when you got that
diagnosis I was married to a great man
but the marriage was not able to outlast
MS and that's very common in the MS is
the second people with MS are the second
youngest and longest living population
and institutions in America so it's
definitely a progressive debilitating
disease so the type-a overachievers herb
in me the day I was diagnosed he got
involved with the National MS Society
you know was a fundraiser was actually
the largest fundraiser in the state of
Pennsylvania and Delaware went on to be
on the board of directors and by the age
of 37 I did become legally disabled from
the effects of MS on my body which
resulted in bilateral loss of both of my
hands so I couldn't use my hands
couldn't feel the left side of my body
and I was choking which is what kills a
lot of us from MS we choke so you have a
problem swallowing so you not only can
you not feed yourself if you could get
fed you can't necessarily swallow the
food all the time right I was struggling
your throat gets like a charley horse
did you ever like a charley horse when
you're working out or like in your feed
or yeah
never my throat though you get it in
your throat it's called rigidity so my
throat would spasm like that Oh so to
try and save myself I moved to
California cause I body temperature
regulation issues I did all this stuff
before IMS took things for me I built
and sold technology companies I was
grateful to have millions of dollars in
the bank and be very successful you did
really well as an entrepreneur and as a
business person throughout your 20s and
by age 30 you you had achieved the the
American dream so to speak except your
health was continuing to dwindle and
that that's you know was so amazing I
did achieve the American dream and I did
I was connected because of my work with
the MS Society and with I worked in
technology so some of the biggest names
in America you know I and I'll do
anything that they tell me to do and
I'll work really hard but you know I ms
was winning at every turn so I went to
Burning Man which is an artist no
judgment self-expression event that
happens in the desert 2011 yeah okay
back when Burning Man was cool yeah back
before it was so commercialized
yeah when when it was like really
hippies and not but anyway so I went to
Burning Man to pray to figure out what
my course was because what was in front
of me was homelessness potentially
institutionalization or I was
contemplating suicide
I do have a daughter and you know it's
not the greatest thing to think of when
you have you know who's in college at
the time but we need to be able to talk
about that too I was just reading this
really sad story over the over the
weekend there's this news anchor and
Detroit Fox 2 News
I think she was a meteorologist is that
right podcast shot she had LASIK surgery
and like the pain was so immense
afterward within I think it was 2 or 3
months she killed herself she has two
young kids and a husband and an ideal
life but and then here's the messed up
part is like would you realize that
there are a lot of people who have had
LASIK surgery who have killed themselves
after having LASIK surgery not because
it makes you go insane clinically insane
that's not it's it's from pain and some
people last longer than others one
who lasted six and a half years but
having burning every second of the day
kind of pain because they messed up the
surgery and realizing like well I hate
to say this for him but he thought that
this was the only path that he had to go
and I think we have such a stigma around
suicide that it becomes this thing that
is both like it becomes cool to get like
real sad and dark and then get suicidal
it becomes a cultural meme but the
honest thing is like we need to be able
to talk about things like euthanasia or
ending your life in a safe humane way in
many ways our friend dr. Christopher
Ryan he talks about how we're often far
more humane to our pets than we are to
two sick people in this country like
like giving people massive like my mom
was was dying you know and her going
through the chemo and radiation and man
she must have been 85 pounds by the end
of all of that and like it wasn't really
living at all and she was just they were
perpetuating suffering in a way and I
didn't know any better at a time that
was the prescription of of Western
medicine so V you've dealt a lot with
with diagnosis and and prescriptions
from other people and and effectively
death sentences how did you how did you
keep hope throughout all of this you
know my parents both of them have passed
and I was fortunate to know that they
were gonna leave this earth so we had
time together and my mom told me on her
deathbed that I came out of the womb
smiling and I've been smiling ever since
so I was born
genetically happy yeah I'm very happy I
am an optimist and the verb in me is a
fighter from Philadelphia I'm a hundred
percent Italian and I'm tarce the Bulls
so like come on did I have a choice but
to be like this overachiever type-a
personality and I just always been a
fighter if they say no that means yes to
me a matter of fact I used to give talks
in the technology sector which is where
I built companies that no is yes you
know if a buyer says to me no that means
well I'm gonna get this deal if they say
to me yes right away they're never gonna
write me the order you know so so I've
just always been that way
and when to Burning Man and realize that
you know praying everyday at the temple
they build a temple there that may be
our health care system where you go and
they say oh you have a sneeze here's a
drug to get rid of the sneeze maybe the
problem was I was listening to our
health care system and maybe it was the
way I was living my life that was a
problem and the beauty about this I will
tell you as I had already started my
path to minimalism so I was six years
and to be a minimalist and I was already
studying Buddhism I was already
meditating I was already moving my body
consciously before I went to Burning Man
the thing I wasn't doing was taking
ownership for my health beyond going to
the doctor and doing what the doctor
told me meaning what was that putting in
my mouth what was my stress level like
how many hours really sleeping I was not
consciously involving those parts in my
wellness program you're sort of
outsourcing your health and I know that
I would do that with doctors and and I'm
still dealing with a lot of health
issues right now because throughout my
20s I took an antibiotic for about ten
years daily and relatively benign I'm
saying this in quotes if you're not
watching this on YouTube the doctor said
it's a relatively benign antibody Goodis
take it every day and so I did I took
every day for over a decade and totally
destroyed my gut I'm dealing with some
some SIBO issues right now so yeah it's
and and realizing like well no one is
going to be as responsible for my health
design no one's gonna care as much as I
do or at least they shouldn't and I
can't just outsources I can get advice
from people and that's advisable to do
that but but I need to take it all into
consideration I need to be willing to
dive in and do my own research as well
and that sounds like that's what you did
that's the path you went down figuring
out what works for you and your body I
really did which now we call that
biohacking you know in the in the you
know the modern day sure so three diet
and lifestyle choices I have
successfully bio hacked my way to the
point where I have not only stopped what
ms was doing to my body I have reversed
every symptom of MS on my body which has
resulted and I no longer take any drugs
for MS I no longer see Western medicine
doctors and I no longer spend any money
on health care which I exhausted in ten
years two and a half million dollars in
liquid assets listening to West
medicine so the fact that my healthcare
today is zero other than insurance
premiums and I do get blood work
fecal urine and saliva studies so I do
pay whatever insurance doesn't cover for
those but that's just to monitor my body
my gut health you know my inflammation
markers all of those things I have
multiple sclerosis epstein-barr
Hashimoto's and Lyme disease oh my
goodness yeah so we did a podcast
episode with with two of my doctors
well one doctor dr. Tommy woods and then
Chris Kelly who run a company called
nourish balance thrive and they take an
integrative medicine approach sort of
what you're talking about here you you
it's so the best of both worlds so
they'll still look at obviously it's
really important to look at studies and
you know we're not rubbing crystals
against me in order to heal my gut but
but at the same time we're looking at
what are alternatives to antibiotics
right because ultimately I can go that
route there's nothing wrong with just
like there's nothing wrong with with
vaccines right like we're not
anti-vaxxers III vaccinate Ella make
sure she's vaccinated so my
five-year-old like yeah we make sure
that you know she has her vaccines but
at the same time it's about being
cautious about what we're putting into
our body and what other people are
telling us to put into our body so you
went through quite a journey and in 2011
you started turning some things around
you change your diet you run a website
and that now can you talk a little bit
about that yeah when when I started my
healing journey of getting conscious my
Italian family and friends were like
what you're gonna you know no one was
really very supportive so I went to
social media actually had some friends
one day they're like we're car we're
kind of tired are you talking about all
this and she just like go to social
media and you're really bossy so you
should just be like paleo boss lady so I
was like okay so I went to social media
I was eating a paleo lifestyle at that
time which for anyone that doesn't know
that's basically fruits vegetables and
protein we don't eat gluten grains
refined sugar dairy and I started a
paleo lifestyle and you talk about hope
the paleo lifestyle was helping me and
then
happened to see a TEDx you guys did a
TEDx I did a TEDx we know how powerful
and amazing those are this was done by
dr. Terry walls and it was the day it
came on YouTube and at that time I could
only use my voice to activate the
computer so I was screaming at the
computer because I was not feeling well
from MS and I was like diet lifestyle MS
and all of a sudden this TEDx came up
with dr. Terry walls and she's like
here's me and a tilt reclining
wheelchair from MS and here she's
standing on the stage and that was the
first hope because I've always been a
fighter and I was not gonna stop
fighting but now I had someone saying I
went from a wheelchair to standing and I
not only stopped when MS was doing to my
body but I've reversed what MS was doing
so I immediately started doing exactly
what she said and to date I am
potentially like one of the most healed
even more than doctor walls and that's
not in a negative way but I don't take
any drugs and she still she doesn't take
any disease-modifying drugs but there
are maintenance drugs that she takes to
support her I take nothing it's so
what's fascinating here is the thing
that gave you hope is you saw a template
you saw the possibility right whereas
before when you were 23 if you go back
to the beginning you were given the
opposite of possibility you were given
pessimism in fact I printed out some
definitions for hope here because hope
is such a slippery word right it's like
it can mean so many things and I looked
it up in the Ana thesaurus specifically
there are all these different words like
desire and wish and expectation and aim
and goal and plan and dream and daydream
and pipe dream expectation expect
expectancy confidence faith assurance
promise and I circled some words here
that when I think of Hope when I say
Hope when I what I'm often talking about
is aspiration ambition optimism and the
way you find optimism quite often as you
see that oh there's a different template
I've been prescribed this one things one
template it's like when we were living
the American dream right it's like
that's one template but it's not the
template and Western medicine works
really great for a lot of things if I've
break my bone I'm not gonna rub crystals
on that either I'm going to get it in a
cast I'm gonna make sure say if I have a
really bad infection I'm definitely
gonna take antibiotics if they're gonna
save my life no question about that it
makes sense to do that same with
insurance you you mentioned I having
insurance I assume it's like
catastrophic insurance so if you get
into a car accident or something because
you're traveling the country right now
in your van and and and doing a tour
before we dive into these questions Sean
if you could put a link to V's Ted TEDx
talk in the show notes and also her
website is called paleo boss-lady calm
you're also paleo balls lady at all the
social medias I believe yeah beautiful
so good TEDx talk it's funny how those
little eight minute talks can have such
a huge impact yeah I highly encourage
our listeners to go check it out so I
think today we're talking about hope
Ryan the the one definition here in the
dictionary that really stood out to me
was well there were two one was wanting
something to happen that's sort of the
loose definition of hope when you have
hope for something you want something to
happen but for me the important part
yeah sometimes you and I mock the secret
not not because we don't believe in like
the power of intention we absolutely do
but we also have to believe in the power
of action you have to couple your
intention with action so when I think of
Hope at its essence this definition
really stood out to me out of all of the
dozens of definitions I have two pages
of hope definitions printed out here
this one stood out the most intend if
possible to do something so v you saw
this TEDx talk and you're like I noticed
something's possible and I intend to do
that I intend to cure myself in fact
when medical doctors often go to to
medical school they very rarely talk
about healing in in med school when they
do it's usually in the context of wounds
like healing a wound but we often don't
talk about the integrative healing in
healing ourselves whether it's our mind
or our guts or our psychology our
physical health a lot of it has to do
with healing the damage that we create
our body's own
amazing job of healing itself if we're
providing it with with what it needs in
order to heal as you found out so we've
got some really good questions here
today let's start with our first
question from John in Minnesota I'm on
board I'm purging get rid of stuff but I
was hoping to feel better about it
I still feel frustrated and not just
calm as I thought I would so I think the
process is not producing the results I'd
hoped for
I wonder if you guys could help me
alright John in Minnesota he's gotten
rid of stuff not except he's kept the
accent yes the accent I know so my wife
is from Minnesota and she at times I
don't know if you ever noticed it with
her Ryan it comes out like and but in
the strangest oh yeah man once she gets
around her family especially like for
some reason it's like this familial
residue and the accidents all come out
thick so what do you think what do you
think about for John Ryan yeah I mean
you know it's it's funny I had a was
that this isn't funny
you know ironic not haha funny funny how
we always use that word when it's not
appropriate anyway
I had a high school kid email me a
couple years ago he was like 17 years
old and he's like hey man I'm in high
school right now I'm having a really
hard time with depression he's like I'm
tired all the time there's some weeks I
don't go to school because he was
suffering from you know specific type of
illness and he was like I have come
across the minimalists and he's like man
for the first time in a long time I'm
feeling hope and I just wanted to write
and asked you is this the answer to all
of my life's problems is this going to
cure my depression is this going to give
me energy and you know I just wrote back
to him I'm like hey man and I'm a PayPal
invoice right the answer is yours for
$19.99 no I just brought it back and I
was like look man minimalism is not this
magic bullet answer of solving all of
life's problems
what minimalism helps us to do you know
specifically Josh and I and what we
write about is how we use this tool to
help us through filter through all of
the noise and the impulses that we face
and it's
just the impulses that we have
personally but the impulses that are
forced upon us in society and yes can
minimalism you know help this said that
you know what I was explaining him you
know can minimalism help you to to live
a more deliberate life yes but no
unfortunately there are you know there
are limits to what minimalism can help
with and I feel very similar towards
John here you know John may have went
into this this journey thinking that all
I'm gonna get rid of my my stuff and I'm
going to be happy
that is I think maybe maybe a bit of a
wrong expectation now I don't think John
is hopeless here I think there's
certainly a lot of hope with John what I
think I would tell him is like dude
congratulations on getting rid of all
this clutter congratulations of
bringing and making your life quieter
and a little bit easier to to maneuver
through this is the very first step into
your new meaningful life that you know
John is trying to live here so now that
he's got all this noise out of the way I
think he has to start asking he he has
to start asking more questions and V I
like what you talked about in your TEDx
talk about getting behind the Y so I
think John needs to start with like why
you know a why did he start minimalism
this journey in the first place and why
is he experiencing this this frustration
or what did he say specifically Josh how
he's feeling he said I was hoping to
feel better about it and he said I still
feel frustrated and not as calm as I
thought I would and the process is not
producing the results I'd hoped for so
the question is is why is John not
feeling calm right now and there are so
many different answers to that right
yeah I mean but ultimately it comes down
to one broad answer then there be
specific answers for him that might be
different from all three of us right and
so if I if I if I'm looking at John and
what he's asking here hope says
something about the future so does
despair so when you feel feel despair
you're saying I don't feel a whole lot
of promise I feel pessimistic about the
future when I feel hope I feel
optimistic about the future so the two
sides are the same
and when I look at what if I'm looking
backward there's there's something
called joy and there's something called
regret if you feel bad about the past
you're gonna feel regretful if you feel
joy about the I feel good about the past
you feel you feel joy right and so when
when you're going in there right and
you're talking to John about changing
the why based on on these TEDx talk to
me the question is how might your life
be better with less that helps you
identify what your Y is because if
you're just getting rid of the stuff
yeah you'll feel a weight lifted right
away like I look my living rooms a
little bit cleaner right or oh well I
can actually see you know my kitchen
counters now all the bills are moved off
of it
you feel a little bit of relief but
you're not gonna experience the joy from
the past you're not gonna experience the
hope of the future unless you know why
you're doing what you're doing and the
way you do that as you figure out what
is your Y how am I your life be better
with less maybe it's finances maybe it's
improved health maybe it is better
relationships maybe it's contributing to
your community maybe it is being able to
grow or read or create things that you
weren't able to do before your Y might
be different from my Y now the thing
that I'm going to say here Ryan is he
said those aren't the results I hoped
for and my question is well what were
the results you hoped for right that's
another way to figure out your Y if it's
nebulous well I was hoping I'd feel
better well what does better look like
you have to get really clear and cific
on on the why not just I hope I'd be
happy well what does that even mean
that's a slippery return then hope even
in fact I often think happiness is the
problem because we're constantly chasing
these are the ephemeral pleasure right
like more and more and more give me more
skittles because it tastes good in my
mouth right now
not realizing like oh I am going to
regret this later right and so if I were
to define hope here I would just say
when it's done well hope is a loosely
held expectation without a specific
destination and what I mean by that it's
not good to be willing to say
we have to be willing to say like I'm I
may not have you know six-pack abs or I
may not have lose this exact amount of
weight that's not the destination that I
want the destination that I want has to
be clear to me based upon what I want
not what the what societal standards are
thrusting upon me so so V I'm sure in
your experience from when you first were
diagnosed with MS up into this point I
know you've done a lot of like
meditation and treats you've done
different talks you went to Burning Man
have you ever had an instance where you
had this hope this expectation of what a
certain experience was going to bring
you for it to just not be what you
expected at all and and I guess I have
you ever had that happen and how did you
deal with it yeah I mean I actually just
had that happen recently I'll tell you
you touch briefly I live in a van and I
tour around the country helping people
for free learn everything that I use and
they can find all those tour dates and
stuff at your website would be yeah so I
was doing that one person at a time in
the community came back to me and said
we'd like for you to do like a hundred
people at a time so I'm like okay sure
I'll do that
so in Colorado this year I did a we
called it a summit a weekend where
people flew in from all over the world
in South Africa I mean countries like
you know South America Europe I couldn't
believe it to spend you know three days
with me and a co-host and I thought this
is me really serving the community and
I'm so proud of myself was like one of
the proudest days of my life until three
days in and I realized that I physically
can't do this i emotionally can't do
this it's a lot it's it it was me
forgetting that I do still have multiple
screw I have all these things I just
managed them and that in order for me to
stay well I need to maintain what it
takes for me to be well and that is not
three days in a hotel with a hundred
people inspiring them at one time takes
a lot of energy so it it it was like a
brick hit my forehead because I'm just
trying to help people that's all I want
to do and I overextended myself and I
actually was now hurting myself trying
to help people so how I regroup was
took off and I went to into Mother
Nature I went to Rocky Mountain National
Park for four days and took a people
detox the outside world detox and just
shut it all down and just hung out with
my dog and I am a minimalist I only live
with seventy possessions so total
everything I own fits insane Millie yeah
everything I own fits in sixty square
feet and to be able to just you know
it's easy to get outside and turn the
outside world off when you live the way
that I do and just to regroup and for me
it was not it felt like a hopeful thing
I was doing was shattered but what it
was it was life just telling me that
that wasn't the best use of what I was
doing and I just had to regroup and
reposition went back to my tribe and
said I can no longer I can't do this I'm
sorry and then they came back and gave
me they get community reignited my hope
some isn't that awesome like when when
you something bad happens and you feel
like oh man like my friends my family my
community I've let them down they're
gonna judge me but like when they come
back and they're like oh no we love you
and we support you it's not like just
the best people really touch my heart
because in those 48 hours that I was in
Rocky Mountain National right I did feel
sad that I'd let I'd let my community
down and I also almost felt sort of like
wow Here I am giving people a message on
how to be healthy the way they live
their life and I like overextending
myself to an unhealthy and I did it in
front of people so I felt like wow and I
was just trying to help I was so focused
on trying to help that I forgot myself
in that journey and that's not really
helping people when you forget yourself
so if you're not there to help if you if
you're not the best version of yourself
then it's not really gonna be helpful
for them anyway you know I'm thinking
about my my recent issues with with SIBO
and all of what John said actually
applies so I've been healing my gut over
the last three years working with the
great doctors over at nourish balanced
thrive we did a podcast with them I
think it was episode 138 shown if you
gonna put a link to it in the show notes
but it was about health problems and
we've healed a whole bunch of issues on
mercury poisoning a bunch of a bunch of
other things and and now recently though
I've had this huge SIBO overgrowth of so
small intestinal bacterial overgrowth
for those of you uninformed and he said
I was hoping to feel better about it lay
I'm sorry cuz I'm taking massive action
I'm 18 days into this 90-day protocol
and I mean you should see a ryan has
seen the amount of pills that I'm taking
every day it's an army yeah and and so
you know my diet is radically changed
and everything but he said I was hoping
to feel better about it
I still feel frustrated and not as calm
as I thought I would be and the process
is not producing the results I'd hoped
for and what I would say is maybe the
timeline is more protracted than what
you think I mean for me it took about
eight months for me to simplify my life
a night when I was letting go of stuff
Ryan did it in 21 days but even then I'm
pretty extreme even then though wasn't
it wasn't over it was its maintenance
after that right and moving on it's
learning about not bringing in the wrong
things as well bringing in the
appropriate it's 21 days like it wasn't
it's not like I woke up and I was like
oh man like life is perfect now right it
was more about after those 21 days I
could see a path I finally was able to
see the path that I really wanted to go
down and yet what I liked about what you
were saying he is you regrouped they
maybe that's where John's at right now
he just needs to regroup and really
figure out what it is that is truly
making him feel this anxiety and and
maybe to regroup to really get clear on
the path that that he wants to take the
other thing too is you learned from this
experience in John buddy like learn from
this experience what would you have done
differently how are you gonna do things
differently moving forward and then the
other thing too is John I know there's
some positive stuff out there I know
there's some positive stuff that John
has experienced from this journey so so
okay so no yeah yeah definitely focus on
those you don't want to ignore the the
negatives either but you definitely want
to call out the positives you John
doesn't want to look in the mirror and
we don't want trying to look in the
mirror and say well
this is all for nothing and then he's
just gonna go back to you know hoarding
newspapers or whatever right like
there's definitely some positive things
that he can take away from this
experience so it's try to focus on those
and then yes just just really consider
what you're going to do differently
moving forward John you might if you
know when I think about things in my
life
that gave me a lot of stress and anxiety
things that made me feel not calm I
usually has to do with being around just
toxic people I'll just say I'm trying to
like find a softer way to say it but
sometimes like you got we've got toxic
people in our lives and they've been in
our lives for a long long time and it's
hard to like to be honest with ourselves
but John I mean take a look at the
relationships that you have take a look
at your health John how how is your
health because I'll say right now like
if if John is living on a twinkie diet
I'm sure he's not
I'm just going to the extreme area but
you know if he's living on a twinkie
diet like oh the standard American diet
yes like yeah you know that that is
going to cause a lot of stress and
anxiety I know that was certainly true
for me my my health I I just didn't
realize how you know drinking till two
o'clock in the morning and then going to
White Castle and doing that you know two
three four times a week like how
exhausted that made me which in turn
caused him to be more stressed have more
anxiety so so John said take a look at
your health is it because you don't have
time for yourself maybe that's what it
is maybe John is just so busy he needs
to reclaim his time I don't know
specifically what it is but John look at
the positive stuff that has happened
through this journey take note of the
things that you want to do differently
but really now is the time that you have
all this clutter clear and now that your
life is a little bit quieter really get
clear on what it is that you want to do
differently and what what changes you
need to make in your life to help your
life to be more calm I want to prescribe
two things to John here one is there is
a really short essay by Derek Siver's
called subtract and I'm just gonna read
the first line of it we'll put a link to
it in the show notes just sippers org
slash subtract he says life can be
improved by adding or by subtracting
the world pushes us to add because that
benefits them but the secret is to focus
on subtracting and then he goes into
this analogy of how we're consulate
trying to add things like it's going to
bring us happiness joy hope but maybe
the hope lies from subtracting getting
down to the place where you can have
hope for your health and your
relationships the other place is because
you've gotten the the superfluous things
out of the way the second thing I would
like to gift you John is a copy of our
book everything that remains I'll hold
it up right here so we talked about why
and discovering your why in this book
Ryan and I wrote three books over the
course of the last eight years one of
them is we call it a y2 book this one's
the Hal to book minimalism this one's
the what to book and really for John you
need to get focused on the why and I
think everything that remains will help
you do that if you like our podcast
you'll really like the audiobook version
of that podcast shot if you could reach
out to John give him that or if you want
the book book version or the audio or
the eBook version we're happy to give
those to you as well move on here I you
know V I feel like we're not giving you
enough time to talk about the why and
and I know that that's something that
you focus on explain cuz Josh and I talk
about it a lot but why is the why why is
that so important to you you know it's
really interesting because that's
something that you know in touring
around and helping people a lot of times
people ask me like what was your why and
my why was me mm-hmm I love myself and
like a lot like a whole lot and that is
not a that was a learned behavior for me
I didn't grow up loving myself I grew up
being self-critical of everything like I
looked in the mirror and IKEA freckles
you're Italian you shouldn't have
freckles your hips are too big your you
know all of those negative things and
for me my why was me and why was it me
because in order for me to be able to
get conscious I had to get in touch with
me you know and like you guys are
talking about you know John getting rid
of stuff in him not feeling better I
didn't really have any expectations when
I started getting conscious about life
other than I felt like that this path
was going to lead me to a different
place that I had been before
and obviously the place that I was
wasn't working out so well for me so I
knew I needed to take a different path
and I felt like I was worth it hmm I was
worth it so a lot of people say they're
wise their kids or their family or their
my why has always been me and I've
always had hope because I I trust myself
and I believe in myself and you know
once I make up my mind to do something
there's no question that I'm going to do
it so for me like when people say oh you
know I don't I because I'm sick I don't
want to change the way I eat because I'm
sick and I'm like well I don't change
the way because I'm sick I eat healthy
because our food system is broken and I
love myself so why would I saw poison
has nothing to do with the fact that I
have MS it has everything to do with the
fact that I love myself so you know my
why is me which no that's great I think
what you're trying to tell John here is
John you're worth a man figure out what
you got to do differently and make in
and make those incremental changes in
your life man you are totally worth it
yes indeed and we'd love to hear what
you all have to say so if you're
listening to this at home if you have a
comment or tip about hope and including
advice for John or any of our other
question askers today anyone in our
audience leave us a voicemail for zero
six two one nine seven eight three nine
you can also email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists comm well air
our favorite comments and tips on a
future episode and stay tuned to the end
of this episode for this week's listen
their comments and tips - my favorite
part so make sure you send those in if
you have any listener comments and tips
about hope or about anything else you're
welcome to : 406 - 1 9 7 8 3 9 Ryan what
time is it you know what time it is it
is time for our lightning round where we
answer questions from social media
indeed we do them so the this is how we
usually do it we're on Twitter Facebook
and Instagram or at the minimalists and
during the lightning round this is where
Ryan and I both do our best and now you
V do our best to answer every question
with just a short shareable less than
140 character response but don't worry
we just talk a lot and then we wrap it
up with a pretty bow oh really
podcast Shawn wraps it up with a pretty
bow and so oh you can find all of our
our pithy answers in the show notes or
all
one one website now our friend Jessica
Lynne Williams she manages minimal
maxims comm for us and so all of our
nice pretty answers are there on one
website all right our first lightning
round question is from Annie I grew up
with parents who believe that success is
working until you have lots of money to
live comfortably how does one maintain
hope of living a meaningful life when
your parents don't believe in that so
you had a lot of money V and were you
living comfortably did your parents have
expectations of you that you didn't meet
no my parents yeah yeah they did
actually I talked about it and my TEDx I
was supposed to work at a grocery store
and find a husband to make babies and
cook and not have a job also eat lots of
flour yeah yeah lots of flour and lots
of high inflammatory vegetables for me
again it's it my whole healing journey
has been self-reflection and I've had to
question societal and cultural norms
along the way and we're all put on this
life to live our own version of our best
life mm-hm and I love my family and I
love my Italian culture but I've had to
navigate how to respect my culture and
my family be it be true to myself and
there's nothing wrong with being true to
yourself any moon and you know I would
just say to Annie that you know don't
discount your right to be happy and your
parents you know I'm a parent and I
provide my daughter with a lot of
thoughts about the way I see things or
believe in things but that doesn't mean
it has to be her house she has to
duplicate that she has a responsibility
to live her life and you know what as a
parent your parents just wants you to be
happy
yeah amen and you know if you can be
true to yourself and and not measure
your life by dollars and cents I think
you will be happy but also you it so in
your late 20s early 30s you had a
considerable amount of money in the bank
but you weren't living comfortably
because you didn't have your health
right right and so you know it's it's
fascinating that we get this very narrow
picture of the good life and for some
reason the the American meme of the good
life and the Western meme of the good
life and now it's become more of a
worldwide meme of the good life has to
do with an abundance of income a comfort
level of income of course if we look at
certain studies depending on what
what country you live in if you by the
way if you live in if you're already if
you're listening to this you make more
than thirty four thousand dollars a year
you're living in the 1% of the world
population also the 1% of human history
as well so congratulations you're part
of the 1% if you make that much money
however that said it doesn't mean that
you're necessarily comfortable I know
really comfortable poor people I know
really comfortable rich people I know
really comfortable middle-class people
and I think the commonality has very
little to do with money yes money does
buy you some creature comforts for sure
however it also it also increases the
demand of what we think we need it ups
the threshold the bar of acquisition
continues to grow higher because of
course I need a four-bedroom house even
though there's two people living here of
course I need the second Mercedes Benz
because the first one is no longer
enough of course I need blank blank and
blank and so our expectations continue
to increase my my short answer here is a
comfortable life is not a virtuous
pursuit and so what I would say to Annie
here is I don't think that's what you
want to pursue of course you want a
certain level of comfort or I think a
better word for that a certainty you
need a certain level of certainty I need
to be certain that these cameras are
reasonably certain these cameras are
turned on and the podcast Shawn is
actually recording this episode I need a
a base level of certainty this light
isn't going to fall on my head as we are
recording this episode you need basic
certainty food clothes and shelter all
those things are really important to
live a meaningful life
however when we're constantly pursuing
nothing but comfort we're nerfing our
entire world that is not a place from
which you will grow at all and so a
comfortable life is not a virtuous
pursuit my short answer is this living
our life for others is disastrous when
we don't consider our own needs because
it is too often that we will put someone
or a group of people's needs above our
own which you know in a I don't want to
sound like I'm being completely selfish
here because that's not what it's about
it's it's about when when I'll give you
a perfect example my father who
is a jehovah's witness right now does
not talk to me because I am knowledge of
I'm living with my my partner Mariah
where you know we don't have a piece of
paper that says we're married even
though like I will probably be with her
the rest of my life so if I was to do
exactly what my dad wanted if I was to
you know get this piece of paper that's
not that big of a deal I mean I you know
I'm we're not traditional that way I
think it's silly that the government has
to be involved with with relationships
but regardless that's not a too big a
video but if I started to do everything
he wanted me to do going and supporting
an organization that I truly just don't
want to support if I if I was going out
of my way to do these things with my
life to live it exactly how my dad
wanted well then I won't be miserable
you could the thing also is you could
make a thousand concessions to him but
there would be a thousand and first
concession right there always yeah there
will always be something else right and
that's a that's actually a great point
because that's that's so true with with
Annie here Annie you could you could
work until you have lots of money to
live comfortably your parents Annie will
probably find something else to to
suggest the way that you should live
your life you have two million in the
bank but now you need three say what is
enough no I mean truly what is at what
is enough money everyone's definition of
enough is different you know a lot of
money and you know I had a lot of money
I had a lot of money for a long time I
never had financial insecurity until
later in life and by society standards I
had everything and I was miserable
and I was sick I mean I was so miserable
and I live under that thirty four
thousand dollar mark okay and I wake up
every day now with joy and happiness and
purpose and before I would wake up
feeling overwhelmed and I was in pain
and I was miserable and I can honestly
tell you that money does not bring
happiness what brings happiness is your
own lens your own narrative what you're
telling yourself what you're believing I
mean I only wore designer clothes
most of my shoes were over a thousand
dollars and everything on my body I was
recycle
from goodwill and you all right by the
way thank you you know so I'm serious
I'm having shawl in the way yeah I think
we got quite a few pithy answers there
for Annie so that you can find something
there for sure
one more thing I'd like to add to is you
know if you're in a situation Annie
where you're not getting support from
your parents and there's no one else in
your life that you're getting support
from Annie you've got to go out and find
people who are willing to support you so
V like you said I went to social media
that's where you went and you started
finding all of these different recipes
and different ways to approach life and
and I mean ultimately that's how we are
in this room together it's because it's
so I mean social media eventually got is
here yeah so um yeah Annie you got to
get out there and find people who are
supportive in your life and if you want
to deep dive into parents we did an
episode about our parents and Ryan I'm
gonna talk about all my mommy and daddy
issues yeah we'll put a link to that in
the show notes what's our next question
Ryan our next question is from grew vlog
isn't hope simply another form of
craving isn't it a kind of desire that a
minimalist would seek to subdue so we're
here to tell people stop hoping no we
would never do that yeah I mean so and
that's why I went through those
definitions earlier I mean there's so
many in some cases the answer is yes if
if we have hope for a bunch of things
that and desires for a bunch of things
we don't know why we're desiring them
like I hope to make a billion dollars
but like well why what and there's a
very specific thing I want to do with
that money maybe that's a little bit
different but if we're just hoping for
these arbitrary metrics and figures and
someone else's hopes then I think it's a
recipe for disaster so my short answer
is hope is the antidote to despair we
talked a little bit about how hope and
despair both say the same thing about
the future and so I the thing I will say
is hope is merely the first step though
you can't hope your way to success you
can't hope your Willet way to good
health a I hope I get healthy one day
I was reading a nice piece of lasagna
chocalate covered lizard right so so
when we talked about the best definition
here hope as a verb a verb it's to
intend if possible to do something
intend if possible to do something so is
what you're wanting to do possible great
and you can hope that it happens however
you also have to do it and so hope is is
is merely the the first step and action
is just as if not more important and in
fact I have a few studies here to talk
about the neuroscience of optimism and
hope Shawn I hope we can put a link to
that was a Freudian slip I hope you will
put a link to both of these studies that
the one of them is called the cerebral
neurobiology of hope and hopelessness
and it is a formal study and then there
is a article in Psychology Today called
the neuroscience of hope and it talks
about willpower or talks about optimism
and what the science behind that is yeah
so I guess I was gonna go to my short
answer but I mean I don't want to have
anything to add about about in terms of
craving because III think of it as
something different from craving like
you didn't I mean maybe you know and it
you craves in a good way you crave to
feel better you hoped to feel better you
hope to continue to feel good but but
it's not one of those desires that it's
not a unnecessary or superfluous desire
right craving to me is I mean hope is a
power stance and craving is not oh
that's a pity answer that's good that's
great no it's absolutely true my short
answer is this and I the reason why I
did I wrote this answer it is to bring a
little bit of clarity of what minimalism
is what it does because it
it is too often that people will they'll
hear the word minimalism and then all
these assumptions start to happen like
oh well if josh and ranan are the
minimalist they must like live in
completely empty yeah a completely empty
box with just stark walls and they have
nothing in their lives or as little as
possible in fact we were walking through
the airport one time and this girl was
like oh that's one of the minimalist
he's the guy that lives with nothing
just a little bit of clarity on what
minimalism can help us do so minimalism
minimalism doesn't eliminate desire it
helps us to be less impulsive in an
impulsive world I wish I could sit here
and say like by all three of our books
watch our documentary you got to
contribute to our patreon and get all
those patreon episodes and then and you
know what if you do that you're going to
eliminate all of your desires and you're
going to never want to buy anything
again I'm one of the minimalist I want
to buy [ __ ] all the time
so so it's it's not about getting rid of
these desires it's about learning how to
deal with these desires that we all face
every single day
PS Ryan PSV we have two more questions
and they are good questions here D asks
how can I sustain a hopeful household so
several people in the house that's
something I have to deal with for sure
it's not just about sustaining my my own
hope but having a whole hopeful
household right I see your note about
hormone monster here I can't wait to
talk about that how do I sustain a
hopeful household when there are several
outside adversaries especially since I'm
raising a teenage son so we'll talk
about hope in households with children
and then also Ian asks what advice would
you give to someone who feels
financially and emotionally trapped in
their life we're gonna answer both of
those questions that if you'd like to
hear our answers to those questions you
can listen to this week's post script
episode over at the minimalists private
podcast that's right each week we record
an additional podcast episode
and it's available exclusively to our
patreon subscribers so if you want to
support our show and keep this podcast a
hundred percent advertisement free then
head on over to the minimalists comm
slash support in addition to our weekly
PostScript episodes
the minimalist private podcast feed
includes our ask the minimalist anything
episodes unreleased recordings of our
live events we did 15 different live
events we released to our patreon
supporters last year exclusively for you
all and you can also check out the
entire back catalogue of past private
episode so I think we're approaching a
hundred private episodes at this point
my goodness so in that that week was
through happiness for us so reproach
your happiness is 200 but you're gonna
have to catch up with us so if you want
to listen to all those PostScript
episodes they are shorter sort of
bite-sized episodes anywhere from 45
minutes or less some of them or even
like 8 minutes long we do these these
short episodes every week you get an
additional episode and once you become a
subscriber you'll also receive a
personal link to our private podcast
feeds to the plays in your normal
podcast player whatever you're using to
listen to this right now like Apple
podcasts or overcast or feedly you find
all the details and all the good stuff
including an additional podcast episode
every week over at the minimalists comm
slash support and here is a snippet from
this week's PostScript episode
[Music]
your budget creates possibilities for
you because if you don't know where your
money is going then of course it seems
impossible and then you feel pessimistic
about the future you feel despair and so
and when you feel despair you feel
trapped because you're saying this isn't
going to get any better that's what ian
is saying he says I feel trapped
financially and emotionally you're
saying I don't feel like this is gonna
get any better I don't see any
possibility of improvement the budget
sheds light on possibility budget is a
little bit of Hope yes absolutely yes it
is a tool for hope okay now it's time
for our added value portion of the show
this is where we each talk about
something that has added value to our
lives recently and in the spirit of more
is less I have two things that I wanted
to talk about this week so there was an
album called first and foremost by an
artist named Plested and it's like
upbeat pop songs about hopeful yearning
and I felt like it was and I just
discovered a couple weeks ago and it
almost made my my top it made my top 15
list last year so I did I do this album
list every year okay so so I put out
this this list and he actually made the
honorable mention so I cut it down to 12
people just because I you know I wanted
to slim it down it just looked better
and have-12 but I've discovered at the
end of the year I think it's seven or
eight songs but they're all great it's
like you put it on you just walk around
for half an hour and you feel upbeat
it's it's a very hopeful album and so
plus tit and also if you want to check
out my year in list you just go to the
minimalists comm slash sound it's called
the sound of life there's a last year's
list and then all the previous year's
list since we started the list that list
is great man I uh there's a couple
albums on there that I had not heard you
recommend or forgot that you recommended
that I was going to remember any of them
trying to think of the the rap album
young boy MBA yeah
yeah I mean he's got like an EP that he
put out but it's because he had about 18
so on okay now the one thing I was like
an 8 I was like an 8 song EPA that came
out this guy 2018 anyway my point is is
that there's just all different types of
music there there's literally raw really
good album free and I'm like and I'm
like discovering yet new stuff that I
didn't even realize how to come out this
year it's great and then I rediscovered
something this week last week actually I
rewatched up in the air and I hadn't
seen this since we were in the corporate
world came out 2009 I saw when it came
ago up in the air it's it is a George
Clooney movie and he's like a perpetual
traveller okay and he's trying to reach
his goal of 10 million airline miles
because that's how much he flies would
be like the seventh person in the world
to do it or whatever but it is this what
a crazy goal and and how what's your
accomplishment in life I flew 10 million
mine well then he has all these other
like little sort of sub goals and it was
this perfect Synecdoche of like how we
get this perceived status he's like look
at my Hilton Honors membership card or
look at my frequent fliers card or he's
comparing cards with some girl in a
hotel bar and like look at all these
reward points that I get and it's funny
how one movie can touch you in a certain
way because we hadn't traveled that much
but I was just living in Dayton Ohio and
the only time I traveled was when I
drove down Cincinnati a few times a week
that was that was the extent of my
travel or maybe we'd get lucky and draw
out the Indianapolis and but now I Ryan
and I have you know we did well I think
last year or in 2017 104 flights or
something insane and and so you you get
this sense of like also there is a
particular kind of loneliness and in
this sort of perpetual in fact I knew
something was wrong in 2014 when we
started saying in a bunch of like
Hampton Garden and our Hampton Inn or
and that started feeling more like home
than my home
yeah and I'm like I look the same it's
like when you go to Starbucks like you
know what you're going to get yeah yeah
and they try hard to create that and
give you the sense of home even though
it isn't there but it was a fascinating
movie and I forgot about the ending and
I'm not gonna spoil it for anyone but oh
my goodness it's such a good flight it
was good even without this ending but
with the ending you're like oh it I mean
it's one of the movies that bowls you
over and I just yeah so yeah it's called
up in the air speaking of movies I saw
Bohemian Rhapsody finally okay have you
seen that yeah I know you haven't talked
about like a movie about hope I mean
it's a great movie I wish I would have
seen it sooner I'm a little jealous cuz
podcast Sean saw it like in the IMAX and
there's like this um the last like 10 15
minutes is a it's not actual Queen it's
like the actors who play Queen but they
put on this concert and it's I can only
imagine seeing it in IMAX would be to be
freaking awesome but one specific thing
I remember about that movie when it
comes to the hope is Freddie Mercury is
trying to talk his I don't his manager
it's not his manager I don't know the
music label whatever it is I know and
he's trying to talk him into like
putting Bohemian Rhapsody as the single
and the guys like that's a six minute
long song without a chorus right like
that's like that's stupid like we're not
gonna do that and he just looked at and
he's like you're gonna be the guy who
let Queen get away and then like they
walked out and to me like that was
Freddie Mercury like a he had the hope
he had his vision but he also put all
the work in the energy into making that
vision come to fruition as much as he
could and then he had this one little
barrier in the way and he just went
right around it and just kept on the
hope and now like Bohemian Rhapsody is
one of the most famous songs and you
have to be willing to walk away to that
that's the from and to me that's a
broader metaphor right because like
walking away from the life that when you
talk about like well Italian family and
Italian food like that's part of my
identity it's part of my cultural
heritage 23andme says I have to
right but then you're realizing like but
wait a minute I can walk away from that
part of my identity which by the way is
the hardest part to walk away from is
this thing that we we get tied up and
say this is part of me and I think it
was our friend TK Coleman who's been on
our podcast a few times he he talked
about recently like if you're not
willing to walk away in a negotiation
it's not actually a negotiation right
it's true yeah you you're just a slave
to their expectations at that point you
always have to be willing to walk away
via what's been adding value to your
life recently in the last year the
number one thing that has been adding
value in my life believe it or not is
CBD okay Wow I'm thinking right now with
the SIBO yeah hemp I have to tell you
and in touring I don't think I'm the
only person saying that but CBD not only
for me but for my dog so CBD oil like
use like a little teacher thing yeah so
it has it's it's not cannabis we're not
talking marijuana we're talking ham so
there's no psychotropic effect but
Mother Nature gives it to us and it's
really been a game changer for me and my
wellness program and one I never saw
coming
helps with information helps with
stabilization of the gut and a few other
things aya tea sleep and you know no
side effects no negative outcomes I love
things that help me that are producing
no negative outcomes and really beyond
remembering to use it it requires
nothing for me yeah I don't know the
technical word but is it is it a CBD
something that you have to build up to
like with Allegra for example if you
know the over-the-counter stuff you've
got to take it for like a week and build
up that drug in your system before you
actually start to experience I think
they're compounding effects but I mean I
noticed right away the first time I ever
tried CBD oil it made me tired but in a
way where it was like it helped it aided
my sleep I generally don't
I personally gentleman I'll take it
every day it's up right now with the
SIBO protocol I'm on they do have me
taking it every day as part of this
entire regimen I mean I think if the if
the FDA like raided my house right now
they would they would arrest me for
intent to distribute supplements take it
so much yeah so yeah make sure it's
legal wherever you are it's silly if
it's not but I assume I think it's
pretty much illegal everywhere in the
United States and Canada at this point
but we have yeah we have listeners in
190 countries at this point so it may
not be legal where you are yeah so just
keep that in mind all right Ryan let's
move on to right here right now so we
talked about what's going on in the
lives of the minimalist I want to talk
about our most recent screen las'
Saturday experience but first I want to
say thanks to V for being here and if
you're listening to this at home I would
strongly encourage you to check out her
website it's paleo balls lady calm check
her out on all the social medias at
paleo boss lady and also check her out
on the road I know you're hitting the
road again and in January so as this
episode comes out you'll be hitting the
road again it's called the taking it to
the street store you can find that over
at her website as well so thank you so
much for being here I hope you realize
that the minimalist your work is a big
part of my wellness program and you've
continued to inspire me and the screen
this Saturday gave me a little anxiety
I'm not gonna lie let's talk about that
what so you have you tried it out at all
well I've been asked to do that a few
times and I I can't let my tribe down I
can't do it so like I have anxiety about
doing it but I want to do it I just have
never been able to bring myself so would
you say you don't want to let your tribe
down it's about like being engaged with
them on a daily basis I do get that it's
funny though because like like we were
talking about earlier sometimes we have
this expectation of how our tribe is
gonna treat us when we do a certain
thing but your tribe loves you v they
support you like they want you to do
what's best for you so I would just
encourage you to not let the tribe get
in the way because they love you so much
like they're gonna forgive you if you if
you take it 24 hours to get back to and
it may not even be they forgive you
they'll applaud you most likely because
the expectations are generally not
theirs they're they're often yours and
by the way if someone else has an
expectation but then that's their
unreasonable expectation I we were
talking about with Annie and her parents
like if they have an unreasonable
expectation it's not my my job it's not
my duty to adjust their expectation it's
to figure out what my own expectations
are myself and we've been playing around
with the screen with Saturday thing now
for three months and there are three
ways to do it basically so it's sort of
a you know there's the you can slowly
wean yourself off of it or you can go
all the way in the first week we did it
we do all the way and there's no screens
whatsoever the easiest way to do it the
reason we started it was like hey let's
just take a day off social media every
week hey Jessica who's our social media
manager she can have the day off she's
not looking to comments or anything like
that she's not sending us stuff to
approve on social media she's just no
social media day and for us no social
media as well so that's step one that's
the that's easing it's dipping your toe
into the water right and then if you
want to slowly walk into the water you
add no computer as well so basically I'm
not gonna do any work on Saturdays or
given myself through the the worklist
Saturday so good no no computer screen
in front of me no social media now
that's actually what Bex and I did last
weekend because I wanted to send a video
to our friend Matthew Vella he directed
our documentary minimalism it was his
birthday on Saturday
and so I just said hey man and screen
the Saturday but I wanted to send you a
video and say hey this really
appreciates you happy birthday brother
and and and so I didn't go completely
screen list which is the third way you
can do you go all the way no screens
including your phone nothing and we've
tried that you put your phone in a
drawer that's great and yeah you panic
at first right like you panicked the
first because especially glad you like
oh no I'm naked where's my where's my
phone yet my very first screen was
Saturday we were in Idaho at a place
called Gold Bug it's hot springs and
it's just like if you're ever if you
ever lucky enough to be in that area
like it's spread on the Idaho Montana
border um but anyway like we're we're
getting ready we were staying the night
we're getting ready to go up the trail
and I was like oh I don't have any
service and man what if Josh he's gonna
hold me I'm like wait a minute it's
Saturday like I don't know how I don't
have to have that flinch like I can
leave this in the car
yeah and it's okay
and like the people closest to me
understand that I don't have my phone
today and they support me on that it is
it is awesome like to give yourself
permission to not care and the nice
thing is you said that expect
expectation beforehand yeah and also the
thing to think about is like I'm
probably not the best person to contact
if there's a true emergency so if it's a
screen with Saturday and I happen to
have ello with me then I mean she's the
only person who would need to actually
contact me if there was an emergency but
if she's there with me or Beck's is
there with me if Ryan cuts his hand off
you know cuz he's operating some sort of
soul on a Saturday please call 9-1-1
call me it's also salah saturday so I
sent the video then we we got to we went
to the Russian bathhouse this week and
I've never done it yet but I see on the
screen here it's called zona Spa I
strongly encourage you to go there I
think it's 50 bucks fifty five dollars
and you get to spend as long as you want
in two three five hours there it's
incredibly you go from the the hot sauna
this weekend is the hottest I've ever
experienced it right 250 degrees whoo 50
I mean it's like we were sitting in
there and we were joking about how
really vota was just cooking us but then
you go then you go into a cold plunge
full it's salinated those 30 degrees so
it's essentially freezing you go from 2
to 20 usually it was 250 last we get to
30 degrees and 220 to 230 degrees and
you feel euphoric I mean it is
unbelievable but also you're getting all
that your your body obviously eliminates
toxins through the skin it's one of the
biggest ways to to get rid of toxins and
so if you're detoxing from anything for
me when I was doing heavy metal detox
especially I had to go four or five six
days a week to a sauna and ordered and I
took niacin and other things that helped
me out with that but yeah it man you
feel amazing afterwards I remember we
were there Ryan you looked and he said
if we could do this every day we'd be
invincible
yeah I seriously feel like that like
it's well the first time I I kind of
felt that sentiment was it was like when
we first moved to LA so it was September
October so it was cold and I want to go
surf and it was like the day yeah cold
you know ish that the ocean was and I
went with no body suit and it was like a
day or two after going to vota and like
as soon as that water hit me it was cold
but I was like this is not that cold
plunge like this is this is not nearly
as cold as that and I was yeah I'd like
told everyone else is in body suits and
shivering and talking about how cold the
water is and I'm like not even my back
yeah no I love it it's crazy like the
especially that cold plunge like I've
never felt so much discomfort and
elation at the same time like it is so
the range of emotions that I go through
one I mean cold plunge it's it's pretty
awesome it's pretty intense
alright I want a dollar from everyone in
this room immediately
I'm still owe me a dollar what are you
talking about I want one from you
because Ryan and I this is last month so
that you can contribute to this in
January so if you if you've got a few
dollars for Christmas and you want to
donate one or more of them now is a good
time to do it Ryan and I are from a
place called Dayton Ohio
and on the west side of Dayton one of
the largest food deserts in the country
40% of the population and Dayton proper
lives on the west side there's not a
single grocery store on the west side of
date and we're trying to change that
we're trying to build a not-for-profit
grocery co-op that doesn't just provide
healthy food options but also provides
education so people know what is healthy
and having access to the the healthy
food but also understand why they need
the healthy food is equally important
because right now they can get food but
as Cheetos it's a local liquor store or
or just just bad food not healthy food
and so if you want to help us change
that we are about thirty thousand
dollars shy right now so we need thirty
thousand of you which I'm on a great
week there's a million people listening
to this so they'll give us like
twenty-five cents I think the minimum is
a dollar so give it a dollar but yeah if
you give a dollar
there's someone's throwing money right
now I get 25 bricks my daughter is going
around now and we're walking around like
West Hollywood or something she'll try
to pick up a brick and like hey well
this help at the grocery store yeah and
I smack it our hands say no give me a
dollar it's just a metaphor Ella we do
need your help though and so Vee thank
you so much for contributing to that and
if you all are willing to contribute
just a dollar we'll help out if you have
more than a dollar that will help out a
lot we didn't reach our $100,000 goal
last year it's a three million dollar
grocery store but we're raising the last
hundred thousand dollars at this point
and so if you all can help us do that
we're less than thirty thousand dollars
away from making this thing happen we
hope to break ground later this year and
then hopefully open it sometime in 2020
I gotta say man even if like it ended
today I mean get into seventy thousand
bucks like that is that's that's pretty
awesome
it's anyone who's given to us V and
everyone else like thank you so much for
your contribution that's that's
incredible means a lot to us we're
really grateful and Ryan and I are
donating $25,000 of our own money to
make this happen so we're also putting
our money where our mouth is here if you
want to help out it's just the
minimalists comm slash dayton the
minimalists comm slash dayton you can
contribute over there if you want to see
the funny video we did about it go to
the minimalists column slash brick and
Ryan and I were trying to steal bricks
from a wall in order to to make it
happen oh and if you want to it's a new
year and a lot of people have New Year's
resolutions I've noticed it on social
media recently a lot of people asking me
about writing and of course I teach a
four week writing class online it's
called how to write better if you want
to find more details about that it's how
to write better or get is a four week
writing class 21 different videos
interactive community over 60 pages of
materials some recommended books to read
as well if you want to learn how to
write better how to develop a writing
habit you want to learn more about
composition and editing you want to
learn about publishing as well all of
that is taught in my writing class how
to write better org is the link we'll
put a link to that in the show notes as
well if you want to comment on this
week's pod
episode you can do so over at
youtube.com slash the minimus also on
YouTube right now we're doing quickie
episodes of the minimalists podcast
we're doing living room conversations we
have a bunch of new ones we're gonna
record really soon also we've had we've
had quite a few over the last several
months so those are going well and they
continue to get better and also house
tours of Ryan's in my minimalist home
since we own nothing it'll just be it'll
be like you're you're following our
realtor into a house great parody we're
gonna do that alright we'll see how that
goes oh and also on youtube you can vote
for which videos you'd like to see so
each week we put up a poll like hey what
video do you want us to post in the next
week and we we give you four different
options of videos that you can choose
from so you could to vote for what
videos you'd like to see and on our
website right now simple Sundays every
Sunday we publish a new piece of writing
or a minimalism rule minimalism tip
minimalism essay a video something on
our website you can get that in your
email inbox if you'd like just head on
over to the minimalists calm in your
email address at the top we'll never
send you spam or advertisements or junk
because we hate that stuff and also we
will send you our show notes to every
podcast you always hear me talk to
podcast Shawn about put that in the show
notes put that in the show notes well if
you're on our email list you'll also get
the show notes every time we put out a
new podcast episode I'm speaking of
simplicity now is the last chance to
sign up for a simple year this is a
course that Ryan and I have participated
in for several years now and we do the
gift giving portion but it's 12 months
of guided simplicity over the course of
an entire year so for 2019 if you're
looking for some guided simplicity you
have different experts from different
areas talking about whether it is
self-care or diet or travel or
gift-giving or the holidays decluttering
your home each month we pick a different
topic and we dive really deep on that
particular topic if you're interested in
12 months of guided simplicity if you're
interested in a simple year then head on
over to the minimalists com
/ simple year you can check out all the
details and read the syllabus over there
Ryan you got anything else for us as
always I just want to encourage people
to read more and get informed also here
are some voicemail comments and tips
from our listeners hi I'm Nancy from
Iowa here's a tip about helping to get
rid of your parents stuff and helping
others at the same time my mom is a
ninety and about to move into a smaller
condo after living in a five bedroom
house on 1.5 acres all of her five
children and 13 grandchildren are avowed
middlemist we contacted a friend who
helps with immigrants and after we
organized my mom's stuff in this segment
of kitchen bedding furniture and books
five churches came with trucks to
distribute these items to needy families
this eliminated the cost to families to
not have to go to second-hand stores to
purchase essentials rather they are
truly donated at no cost to them hi Josh
and Ryan its Laura from Melbourne I've
just got a suggestion for changing
habits and particularly around housework
so instead of procrastinating about
having to spend two or more hours
cleaning your house each week break
house chores into tiny daily habits I
tried to make it fun and easy to
remember so it's almost like a bit of a
game in my head so I have the following
toilet Tuesday's washing Wednesdays
throwout Thursday's Fleur Friday's
shower Saturdays that way each task only
takes five or ten minutes and you can
always remember which task to do on what
day and you avoid wasting time
procrastinating or losing valuable time
out of your weekend hey guys this is
Eric from Jacksonville Florida and I
wanted to share a tip that I had that
our family had done last year for her
daughter's seventh birthday and she was
totally into it we had on the
invitations and lulav presents to bring
a small shoebox full of gifts for poor
children in Africa is actually through
Operation Christmas Child Wednesday a
religious organization Christian
organization but there are other
charities like that and our daughter
really enjoyed it and all the kids and
the parents thought was a great idea
also the other
friends parties in which they've asked
in lieu of gifts for people to bring
socks blankets that sort of thing for
the homeless just wanted to run that tip
ayah and people asked about kids
birthday parties and how to avoid all
this stuff all right Joe that's it for
this episode if you have a question for
the minimalists give us a call for zero
six two one nine seven eight three nine
and oh and if you would fall of V over
it at paleo boss-lady and paleo
boss-lady comvee thank you for being
with us today also if you have a voice
memo you want to send to us you've a
comment or tip for the minimalist that
we're gonna play at the end of each
episode podcast at the minimalists comm
is the email address and if y'all leave
here today with just one message we hope
it's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time and minimus